so good morning and welcome everyone
um it's a so good to to see a full house
here with us today also we want to thank
you to thanks and to welcome those uh
people that are joining us online I'm
Jose Luis with the Communications
Department at the IMF and we are here
today for the introduction and the
launch of the latest edition of the
world economic Outlook if Duke haven't
had uh access to the flagship yet I
would recommend you to visit our website
imf.org there you will be able to get
the latest document the full document
but also other assets like the blog
author by plvm and the data that it's
underlying some of the charts and tables
of of them of the wheel and I think that
this is going to be very helpful for
your reporting here with us today our
plague he's the economic counselor and
the director of the research Department
also with
she's the deputy director of the
research department and Daniel Lee he's
a division Chief also at the research
Department the Olivier is going to start
with some opening remarks and then we
will proceed to take your questions I
want to
reiterate that we will be also taking
questions from those reporters that are
joining us online and I want to remind
everyone that there's a simultaneous
interpretation for the press conference
that it's on the record within a further
Ado P Olivier the floor is yours well
thank you Jose
um and welcome everyone the global
economy remains on track for gradual
recovery from the pandemic and Russia's
war on Ukraine China's reopened economy
is rebounding strongly supply chain
disruptions are unwinding while the
dislocations to energy and Food Markets
caused by the war are receding
the massive and synchronized tightening
of monetary policy by most central banks
is starting to bring inflation back
towards its targets at the same time
serious Financial stability related
downside risks have emerged
in our latest forecast Global growth
will bottom out at 2.8 percent this year
before Rising modestly to three percent
next year almost unchanged from our
January projections Global inflation
will ease although more slowly than
initially anticipated from 8.7 percent
last year to seven percent this year and
4.9 next year
this year's slowdown is concentrated in
advanced economies where growth is
expected to fall to 1.3 this year before
increasing modestly next year
by contrast emerging market and
developing economies are already pushing
ahead in many cases with year-end growth
accelerating to 4.5 percent this year
from 2.8 percent last year
the recent banking instability reminds
us however that the situation remains
fragile once again downside risks
dominate
first inflation is much stickier than
anticipated even a few months ago while
Global inflation has decline this
reflects mostly the sharp reversal in
energy and food prices but core
inflation excluding energy and food
prices has still not peaked in many
countries it is expected to decline to
6.2 percent this year still well above
Target
activities to show signs of resilience
at this point in a tightening cycle we
would expect to see more signs of output
and employment softening instead both
output and inflation estimates have been
revised upwards for the last two
quarters suggesting stronger than
expected Global demand this may call for
monetary policy to tighten further or to
stay tighter for longer than currently
anticipated
there is little evidence of an
uncontrolled wage price spiral nominal
wage inflation continues to lag price
inflation implying a decline in real
wages
but labor markets are still very tight
in many countries
this suggests real wages should increase
and we expect they will
corporate margins have surge in recent
years this is the flip side of steeply
higher prices but only modestly higher
wages and should be able to absorb much
of the rising labor costs on average
as long as inflation expectations remain
well incurred as they are now that
process should not spin out of control
more worrisome are the side effects that
the sharp policy tightening of the last
12 months is starting to have on the
financial sector
we have repeatedly warned this would not
be an easy ride
following a prolounged period of muted
inflation and low interest rates the
financial sector had become too
complacent towards maturity and
liquidity mismatches last year's rapid
policy tightening triggered sizeable
losses on long-term fixed income assets
and increased Bank funding costs
the brief instability last fall in the
United Kingdom's guilt market and the
recent banking turbulence in the United
States illustrate instead that
significant vulnerabilities do exist
both among Banks and non-bank financial
institutions in both cases financial and
monetary authorities to quick and strong
action and so far have prevented further
instability broader markets have
remained calm and volatility has been
contained including for emerging and
developing economies
increasing funding costs and the need to
act more prudently however may push
Banks to cut down lending further in a
world economic Outlook we explore such a
scenario and find that it would lead to
an additional 0.3 reduction in output
this year
yet the financial system May well be
tested even more nervous investors often
look for the next weakest link as they
did with Credit Suisse a globally
systemic but ailing European Bank
financial institutions with excess
leverage credit risk or interest rate
exposure too much dependence on
short-term funding or located in
jurisdictions with limited fiscal space
could become the next Target so could
countries with weaker perceived
fundamentals
a sharp tightening of Global Financial
conditions will sometimes called a
risk-off event would have a dramatic
impact on credit conditions and public
finances especially in emerging market
and developing economies
it would precipitate large capital
outflows a sudden increase in risk
premium a dollar appreciation in a rush
towards safety and major declines in
global activity amid lower confidence
in such a severe downside scenario
Global growth this year could fall to
about one percent an outcome was
probability we estimate that about 15
percent
well therefore entering a tricky phase
during which economy growth remains Low
by historical standards Financial risks
have increased yet inflation has not
decisively decisively turned the corner
policymakers will need a steady hand and
clear communication
First Financial with financial
instability contained monetary policy
should remain focused on bringing
inflation down
but stand ready to adjust promptly as
Financial developments might demand a
silver lining is that the contraction in
Bank lending could partially mitigate
the need for further monetary policy
tightening but any expectation That
central banks will prematurely surrender
the inflation fight would have the
opposite effect lowering yields
supporting activity beyond what is
warranted and ultimately complicating
the task of central banks
fiscal policy can also play an active
role by cooling off economic activity a
tighter fiscal policy would support
monetary objectives appropriately
designed fiscal consolidations can help
rebuild much needed fiscal buffers and
help strengthen Financial stability
something that we explore in Chapter 3
of our world economic Outlook while
fiscal policy is turning less
expansionary in many countries this year
more could be done to regain fiscal
space
regulators and supervisors should
strengthen oversight to ensure any
remaining Financial fragilities don't
morph into a full-blown financial crisis
for emerging market and developing
economies this also means ensuring
proper access to the Global Financial
safety net including the imf's
precautionary Arrangements access to
Central Bank swap lines where relevant
and foreign exchange Reserves
exchange rates should be allowed to
adjust as much as possible unless doing
so raises Financial stability risks or
threatens price stability in line with
our integrated policy framework
our latest projections also indicate an
overall slowdown in medium-term growth
forecasts five-year ahead growth
projections declines steadily from 4.9
in 2011 to 3 this year
some of this decline is predictable
growth slows as countries converge but
some of the more recent slowdown may
also reflect more ominous forces the
scarring impact of the pandemic a slower
pace of structural reforms as well as
the rising and increasingly real threat
of geo-economic fragmentation leading to
more trade tensions less direct
investment and a slower pace of
Technology adoption and Innovation
across fragmented blocks fragmented
world is unlikely to achieve progress
for all or to successfully tackle Global
challenges such as climate change or
pandemic preparedness we must avoid that
path at all costs thank you
thank you Olivia and before we open the
floor to your questions get some ground
rules if you want to ask a question
raise your hand wait till I call you and
if I do please identify yourself and the
media Outlet you represent and try to
stick to just one question there's a
full room and we want to answer as many
questions as we can and also I want to
remind that uh Petty and Daniel are
going to be able to answer questions on
regions and Country a specific questions
related to the Outlook only then later
this week we will have Regional press
briefings where other issues when it
comes to Regions and countries can be
can be tackled so uh with this set I
think that we're going to start here on
the on the right with uh David loader
Reuters
thank you uh Pierre Olivier
um
hi thank you Pierre Olivier um
you mentioned uh a lot about the
financial risks that we're facing
um and the wio itself goes into sort of
two separate scenarios sort of a milder
downside scenario and then a really bad
one that's more of a financial crisis
I'm just wondering
um if you can sort of tell us just How
likely we are to see these events
happening uh given the heightened
sensitivity that markets now have
to to stress in the in the banking
system and the non-bank system
um and then what effects you might see
once we have that on on Emerging Markets
particularly uh how bad will it get for
them thank you
well so we explore we do expose you
point out in in our report both we have
a baseline scenario then we have a
plausible alternative scenario where we
take into account the contraction in
Bank lending that could be coming as a
consequence of the financial uh
turbulence we had in uh in the last
month and then we have a more extreme
scenario where we try to quantify what
would be the effect of a full risk-off
event with a large impact especially on
emerging market and developing economies
um to answer your question when we do
the assessment of the probability
distribution if you wanted the outcomes
we find that reaching something like a
one percent growth rate for Global
output which would be a very very low
growth rate by historical standards
something that we've only had maybe five
times in the last 40 years or so has a
probability of about 15 that's so that
gives you a sense of of the the
likelihood if you want but more more
broadly what I want the point I want to
make here is that we've had some
turbulence in the last month and
authorities have responded very strongly
very forcefully some lessons have
clearly been learned from the global
financial crisis and also we should
point out that uh the banking system in
particular is in much better health
overall even if there are pockets of
instability than it was 15 years ago so
all of these are are good things and
they've been uh useful in helping to
contain the risks that we are facing but
we do recognize that there is a certain
amount of nervousness in the markets
right right now that there are maybe
some lurking vulnerabilities and this is
why it's very important at this point
for financial supervisors Regulators
authorities to really go and and look
very carefully at these pockets of
vulnerability that might still exist
whether in the banking sector in a
non-bank financial institutions and more
broadly
okay let's move to this side uh first
first row
ft
thank you Cristiano's from the financial
times you recommend to policy makers
that they should stay the course on
military policy and fiscal policy unless
things get really bad can you define
what really bad is and how close did we
get in early March
well that we've had a lot of discussions
around this very topic as you can
imagine in the last in the last few
weeks and we're still we're still
debating it internally I think the the
way I would articulate it and the way we
articulate it in our world economic
Outlook is that our assessment at this
point is that the financial risks appear
reasonably well contained and given that
they're reasonably well contained it
makes sense for monetary policy to stay
focused on its price stability
objectives and financial instability
that emerges whether it's an individual
bank or individual financial
institutions can be addressed with
financial policies liquidity facilities
or the interventions for instance in the
US we had the deposit Insurance uh
coming in and that allows monetary
policy to remain focused on the price
stability objective if we were to find
ourselves and we let me be very clear we
are not in the situation if we were to
find ourselves in a situation of
systemic financial crisis maybe even
beyond the uh adverse scenario that I
described to you a minute ago then it's
very clear that objectives of financial
stability we take precedence over uh
price stability in a near-term it
doesn't mean that you would abandon any
nominal anchor but it means that in the
near term you would have to put
Financial stability first
where is that transition where you go
from one to the other it's a bit of a
fuzzy area as you can imagine and it's
one we're exactly trying to sort of
think about more carefully but our
assessment at this point is we're not
near at all that uh sort of causation
transition region so monetary policy
needs to stay focused on price stability
there is a very important reason for
this which is that if at this point
saddlebags were to Pivot away from Price
stability then there is a chance that
the fight against inflation would not
succeed inflation expectations would
stop Rising inflation would be even more
persistent and that in itself is also a
source of microeconomic instability and
that would feed even potentially further
later on into Financial instability as
well so we would not be gaining on any
front
okay
we're gonna go
data first row and then we will move to
the side
um good morning
so the question is about Russia IMF has
erased the estimated growth for Russian
economy this year and adjusted it for
2024 although it is still expected to
grow uh 1.3 percent so simultaneously
imfc's doubling digit shrink in oil
prices this year and still sound
correction in 2024 for
5.8 percent so in this case what are the
driving factors for the Russian economy
to grow for these two years thank you
purely there before we we answer there's
there's another question on rasa from a
Tas on WebEx but I will formulate the
question on the reporters we have as the
IMF increased the projection for
Russia's GDP to in 2023 to 0.7 but
decreased in 2024 to 1.3 percent I
wonder what are the reasons for such
changes are they related to the actions
of the Russian authorities
thank you so let me let me uh provide
some elements and then I will turn it
over to my colleague Patia here so on
Russia we have indeed a revised upwards
or projection for 2023 to 0.7 percent uh
that's an upward revision by 0.4
percentage point and we revised downward
for 2024 to 1.3 percent that's the
downward revision by about 0.8
percentage point so what is our
understanding of what's happening with
the Russian economy here uh well one
thing we had in 2022 and and and we're
going to get less of it in 23 and and
possibly into 24. there was a very
strong uh source of revenues for the
Russian economy from energy exports very
very high energy prices and that helped
support economic activity in addition to
that there was a very strong fiscal
impulse in Russia in in 22 and
continuing into 2023 but if we look
forward what we see is we see as we
pointed out oil prices declining we've
seen that the price of the oil sold by
by Russia in some cases is as has been
substantially marked down compared to
other uh oil index indices and we
anticipate that the revenues were
actually be coming down the revenues
feed into fiscal revenues as well so
that will make the fiscal situation a
little bit more complicated from the
point of view of the fiscal authorities
and that goes into some of our
projections for 23 and 24.
thank you just to add a few thoughts
here it's also important to think about
where growth was last year which was at
minus 2.1 so in a way the recovery that
we see this year is partly just the base
effect of of that and in addition we saw
a very strong fiscal stimulus a lot of
it related to defense expenditures in
the second half of last year so the
impact of that is also expected to to
carry over this year as well now all of
being all of that being said in the
medium term we're still projecting
potential growth to be significantly
lower than it was pre-war at about 0.8
and at the same time the level of output
in the medium term we're expecting it to
be uh lower by uh Point by seven
percent altogether
we're going to move to this side
the guardian
of the Guardian you're saying that we
owe that you see no signs of a wage
price Spar but what we are seeing are
widening uh corporate profit margins so
is that an IMF speak for greed inflation
on the part of the corporate sector
which is using higher higher inflation
as an excuse to drive through higher
prices and gouge their customers
so what we what we have uh looked at is
the decomposition of the uh increase in
prices and you can look at it from a
sort of uh uh uh an income Source
perspective and when you do that this is
where you see that uh the increase in
unit label cost is only part of it and
you have a substantial part of the
increase in in price especially GDP
deflator that's coming more from the
corporate side uh now this is not
describing motive to uh why that is an
important component what you have here
is a situation where you had a very
strong surge in demand there's a strong
aggregate demand component uh to uh to
the surging inflation that we've seen
and in a context in which there was
still limited Supply we had Supply
disruptions and things like that
especially in Goods sectors first but
then Services were also affected then
you have a sort of a natural response of
the economic system is that prices will
rise to uh to adjust wages tend to take
some time to adjust because there are
typically adjusted less frequently than
prices and so that's why we went
participator we're going to have this
some of this catch up going forward
okay uh we're gonna go right now to
WebEx for a second uh I think our
colleagues from NHK are ready to ask a
question please go ahead
[Music]
uh yes I mean we we had in the in the
context of Japan and I will I will then
turn it over to my colleague Daniel over
here but we had a relatively
disappointing uh last quarter of the
year and so we have a downward revision
both for 2022 uh to one percent and
there's a carryover to uh to 2023 uh in
the context of relatively weak uh weak
investment so this I think is one of the
one of the drivers of the numbers uh the
revision in numbers that we have but uh
Daniel up to over to you thank you yes
as you said the last quarter of 2022 was
more disappointing especially on private
investment there was some uncertainty
connected with the volatility of the yen
um
and that no has a knock-on effect also
on 2023 which is why there's a downward
revision there
at the same time if you look at the
forecast of growth it's going up for
Japan from one percent in 2022 to 1.3
percent
in 2023 and this support this reflects
the supportive monetary policy
um in particular uh
uh the inflation rate is also uh
starting to go up but it's very low by
International standards and that's why
there is still this monetary policy
support which which we support as well
we're gonna go to the left at Conway
news
thank you uh at Conway from Sky News
um six months ago the UK was one of the
big talking topics here in Washington
after the mini budget and what was
happening in the guilts market I just
wanted you know six months on whether
what's happened since is you know
cautionary tale or have things actually
is is it an exemplary case and what to
do when you're faced with a crisis like
that how is the UK doing right now
before we reply there's there's another
question from Bloomberg news on the UK
can you explain why the IMF is still
expects the UK to be one of the worst
performing economies fiscal risks have
receded and recent economic data has
been resilient this is from Tom Reese
bloomer
yes thank you uh so on on the UK uh
first on the on the financial part the
the brief instability in the in the
guilt Market uh it's certainly the case
that there was forceful action by the
bank of England and I was able to uh to
calm the markets very quickly I mean
it's one of the episodes we've had of
this uh uh rapid increase in in interest
rates uh creating some pockets of
vulnerabilities in the in the financial
sector in that case in uh vehicles that
were associated with uh with the UK
pensions
um so certainly as we've seen also in
the US uh forceful action from financial
and monetary authorities was was very
decisive decisive here uh on the on the
UK numbers let me point out that uh
first we've had a a stronger first
quarter of the year in the UK and in
fact we've had an upwards revision to
our projections for 2023 uh it's still
negative negative 0.3 percent but it's
an opportunity division by about 0.3
percentage points so we are seeing a a
little bit a better performance for the
UK economy
um there is a slightly less physical
contraction in in the pipeline as we as
we interpret it but at the same time
there is also the effect of tighter
Financial conditions which we expect to
see uh playing out in in a number of
countries
um now the the some of the reasons why
uh in terms of levels the UK economy
seems to be doing a little bit worse
than some other uh comparable economies
have not been different from our
previous analysis which is basically
there is a higher dependence on on uh on
imported energy with a high share of gas
and with the gas prices we've had last
year that's a major terms of negative
terms of trade shock uh that it's a
fairly tight labor market and so there's
been a need for a fairly aggressive
tightening of monetary policy and and
there is some effect some already some
signs of the transmission of this
monetary policy to the to the Border
economy but let me ask maybe uh to uh
complement this sure I don't have
anything to add
we're gonna go through the third row
here Eric Martin Bloomberg
yes thank you very much um here Olivia
I'd like to ask about the um the outlook
for distressed debt in uh low-income and
developing countries and we've seen a
growing need for and growing demand for
IMF uh financing IMF assistance and I
wanted to ask about the vulnerabilities
there on an environment of uh high and
Rising interest rates whether uh the IMF
has Quantified uh in terms of the amount
of support that will be necessary or the
amount of of debt coming due and if you
could speak to the potential spillover
effects there are we at the cusp of a
potential uh broader crisis in uh in
developing and Emerging Markets
yes well Eric you're absolutely right to
point out that there are a number of
countries out there who are facing very
very severe and difficult situations
especially when it comes to sovereign
debt uh that's something that has
started already last year when we had uh
the uh the strengthening of the US
dollar that was Associated also with uh
you know lots of movements in capital
flows and and an increase in spreads uh
that was not uniform it's not it's not
been a broad sell-off of emerging and
low-income countries but it's been quite
differentiated but with some countries
facing uh very uh very difficult uh
situation and so we are we're estimating
that at this point we have about still
60 percent of low-income countries that
are in in that distrust or or a high
risk of that distress and about 25 of
emerging market economies are also at
high risk and facing sort of default uh
like uh type of spreads and so that's a
situation that requires action of course
uh there is limited uh in some in some
cases that are limited levers at the
level of the countries because they have
you know by definition they have almost
no fiscal space
um and so some of these require this
starting discussions with uh with with
creditors maybe to think about uh how to
how to uh uh how to reprofile or how to
adjust the the debt trajectory going
going forward of course the fund is
involved in many of these discussions
and we have uh we have various vehicles
to try to facilitate these kind of
discussions for instance the common
framework uh which has been in place
since uh since 2020 has not uh yet been
widely adopted or widely helpful but is
already starting to bear fruit I mean
we've had one case that was completed
under the common framework that was Chad
and then we have discussions that are
underway taking quite a bit of time but
there is some progress in the case of
Zambia and then there is Ethiopia in
Canada also uh under under discussions
under the common framework
I'm gonna take the first two row here
and then I'm gonna move to the side of
the room
thank you sriram lakshman from the Hindu
um my question is about India uh the
growth rate for fiscal year 2024 has
been uh down revised by 0.5 percentage
points to 6.3 so I was just wondering if
you could comment on the reasons for
this on and more generally the overall
outlook for the economy and um also if
this is something you can answer here um
the job situation the medium-term
employment and job situation and outlook
for that country thank you
thank you yes we have a growth rate for
India
which is 6.8 in 2022 let's not forget
this is one of the bright spots in the
global economy right now such a high
growth rate and it is moderating down to
5.9 with a minus 0.2 uh
revision compared to January What's
Happening Here is also a set of
historical revisions we realized that
2020 2021 has been actually a lot better
than we thought and so actually there's
less room for catching up and that
pent-up demand which
from consumption that was informing our
previous forecast is therefore going to
be less because they've already had more
catching up before
so that's why uh there's the downward
division this year then we go up to 6.3
next year again a very strong economy
which is necessary to allow India to
continue to converge towards higher
living standards and create those jobs
that are necessary
and I have also questions on Argentina
if you're going to ask on Argentina
thank you
I have a question yes on Argentina
um you're projecting a modest uptick in
GDP of 0.2 percent and a drop in
inflation to 88 annual by the end of the
year uh this goes up on the opposite
direction of private projections in
Argentina we are seeing inflation going
up and there's in a recession you know
uh amidst the historic drought why are
you seeing inflation uh going down this
year in Argentina thanks my name is a
few oh yeah I have a few questions still
in Argentina but on the same kind of
line of questioning from info by I would
like to know your opinion about the
situation of the high inflation low
level of international reserves and the
multiple exchange rates in Argentina and
from clarine a question about Argentina
why is the IMF downsizing the GDP
projections from 2023 and what Argentina
should do in order to grow
so let me say a few things and then I'll
ask a picture to provide additional
details uh first on Argentina the the
reason for the large download revision
of output for 2023 is is very very clear
it's the drought uh it's a massive a
massive drought and it's having a huge
impact on the economy it's expected to
be transitory so we're revising downward
Argentina's growth rates for 2023 but uh
2024 is expected to be a two percent
which is uh sort of more or less on
average on the inflation front we had
seen some progress but of course the
recent economic challenges have actually
led us to revise upwards uh there are
inflation numbers for Argentina so so
yes it's 88 but it's it's up from before
that in January we're expecting to be
coming down to 60 so it's it's coming
down a lot less but let me take lower
too
yeah just maybe a couple of other
um thoughts so we uh we just we saw in
when it comes to growth we saw a fairly
sharp slow down in the last quarter of
2022 so some of that impact is expected
to to carry through this year and of
course the the impact of the drought is
the reason for the significant downgrade
of growth for this year so when it comes
to inflation inflation ended the year
last year at 94.8
percent which was a very large number
and and we also saw a pickup in January
although part of that was because of the
food prices
so the underlying inflation pressures
are still there and part of that is
because of the unanchored inflation
expectations so in the way I would
characterize our projection is that we
are actually expecting inflation to to
stay high and to stay at very high
levels in although which actually
prompts the question of what has to be
done and this is where the importance of
macroeconomic policies having
tight monetary policy as well as fiscal
policy which is in line with what is in
the in the fund supported program would
be particularly important
we're going to go quickly to WebEx I
think we have GK news
go ahead
we cannot hear you
okay so we're going to continue here in
the front
thank you Simon ativa from today news
Africa and Washington DC as you know
Nigeria which is the most populous
country in Africa has just gone
underground a presidential election won
by Ebola tinubo uh do you have if you
can talk a little bit about the economy
of Nigeria the projection and some of
the recommendations that you make to Mr
tinubu will be sworn in next month and
more generally about Africa if you can
talk a bit about the economy in
sub-Saharan Africa and you know some of
the recommendations that you have thank
you
before you you answer I know that we
have a fellow uh that it's also from
Africa please go ahead and ask your
question it's Heidi jokes from South
Africa
um your projection for South Africa
growth is at 0.1 percent mostly linked
to the energy crisis perhaps if you can
just go a little bit deeper into that if
you can thank you
so let me say a few words about the
sub-Saharan Africa and then I will ask
Daniel to come in on Nigeria and South
Africa more specifically so so very
clearly the region is suffering from a
strong funding squeeze that we already
discussed I mean some of the some of the
countries that are facing a very
elevated spreads a lot of them are are
in the region a lot of the challenges
come from external factors the very the
surge in Energy prices and food prices
as a consequence of uh the Russian
invasion of Ukraine and the tensional
energy markets is affecting is affecting
the region so we have we have a slowing
growth for the region overall to about
3.6 percent in 2023 from 3.9 percent
last year we also have a situation where
inflation is is elevated it's double
digit inflation expected to come down
from 16 roughly 16 to about 12.3 but
still still they're about double duty
inflation and of course a very important
challenge for the region is uh as a
result of this elevated food prices we
have a large number of people who are in
situations of food insecurities we
estimate about something like 130
million people in situation of food
insecurity
thank you thank you for Nigeria our
forecast is one of the most stable ones
uh for this year we have an increased
slight increase
[Music]
um
we have 3.3 percent in 2022 that's an
upward revision and uh for 2023 about
the same 3.2 3 in 2024 so this is
um
an economy with very high inflation as
well and this is why we have a forecast
of about 20 percent for 2023 and one of
our main recommendations is to uh
tighten the monetary policy to
ensure that this inflation comes down
towards the more Target levels so that's
uh for Nigeria for South Africa this is
an economy where we have a sharp
slowdown to about 0.1 percent growth
this year that's a minus 1.1 percentage
Point revision and this mainly reflects
the much more severe than expected
altitudes in the energy sector
especially in the last quarter of uh
2022 but next year we expect more power
to come online
and the growth to to recover to 1.8
percent
uh more Renewable Power in particular
should be connected
on the inflation front the infection is
forecasted to come down to inside the
target range of the South Africa Reserve
Bank 5.8 percent in 2023 and then
continue coming down 4.8 percent so we
did Welcome the recent increase in
interest rates uh to 7.75 percent that
is why we expect inflation to converge
to the Target
okay we're running out of time we're
going to go back to WebEx and then go
back to the room so GK news if viewers
there please go ahead
[Music]
um
threat of geoeconomic presentation
leading to more trained intentions thank
you
so on on China we have of course this is
one of the one of the bright news for
for 2023 uh the the rapid reopening of
the economy is leading to a strong
rebound
um so we're projecting 5.2 percent
growth in 2023 that's up from three
percent last year so very clearly uh uh
um you know very significant in fact and
and of course
still some slack in the in the Chinese
economy so inflation
pressures remain remain quite modest and
we anticipate that there will be mostly
around two percent this year and and
next year are increasing a little bit
maybe next year 2.2 percent one of the
one of the uh um risks uh looking ahead
for the Chinese economies of course the
property sector uh there's been some
concerns already expressed you know last
year in terms of the uh the the extent
to which the property sector might weigh
down on growth uh given the the weakness
we see there and there are a number of
measures have been have been implemented
but more could be done to make sure that
this uh this uh uh process this sector
uh stops Contracting and uh doesn't drag
down growth in China going ahead there
is also some discussion about the extent
to which uh the Chinese reopening leads
to a surge in consumption so far that
seems to be there but it's not maybe as
strong as we've seen in in other
countries so there still may be a little
bit of a prudent behavior on the part of
households and and consumption
um but uh this is uh certainly something
that is contributing overall the
reopening is contributing to uh to
Global growth with with positive
speedovers uh Daniel anything to add on
China
only about those spillovers that so far
in the region we haven't seen as big an
impact as we might have expected in the
past from such a strong Chinese rebound
and one of the reasons that this is a
growth rebound that is more concentrated
in the domestic Services than in the
past where it was more investment-led
and so that has a smaller impact and
also our medium-term forecast for China
is moderating so that also means less
positive spillovers to other countries
around the world
okay we're gonna go for the last
question we're gonna go here in the
front row
um
online Egypt
the report has downgraded the Egypt's
real GDP growth for the second time
since October so I want to know what are
the key drivers for this downgrade also
I want to to know your insights on the
countries
that
especially that Egypt is currently
engaged in an eff program that charts a
clear map to lower its GDP over the
medium term thank you and we have
another question on Egypt from Fatima
Ibrahim that goes kind of on the same
line saying uh what are the expectation
expectations for the performance of the
Egyptian economy during the current year
[Music]
countries across the world and we have
downgraded the forecast for this year by
0.3 and by 0.3 also for the coming year
and part of that the lower growth in
this difficult external difficult
environment is related to the external
environment and the very high financing
costs that Egypt is facing at the same
time we've also seen the depreciation of
the currency and its impact on the
economy as well as the continued backlog
of
um of imports as well as a rationing of
FX so all of these factors have lowered
business and consumer confidence and
that is what is underpinning this lower
growth this year and next all of that
being said we're still talking about
growth being at 3.7 this year and five
in 2024. and when it comes to the
engagement on policies as you know
indeed Egypt is is being supported by a
by a fund program and the uh there there
is preparation right now for the for the
first review of the eff
thank you
okay so uh in the name of uh Pier
Olivier Petty and Daniel and the
research department and the
Communications Department I want to
thank you everyone for attending this
press briefing I want to remind you that
the next press briefing is going to be
at 10 30 a.m for the launch of the
Global Financial stability report then
tomorrow we will be launching the fiscal
monitor early in the morning and as I
said later on the week we will have all
those Regional press briefings so thank
you very much for attending if you have
any other questions or comments sending
my way to Media imf.org thank you very
much